my name is banku I'm from gy University
from Beijing and today my talk is about
how to deliver computational thinking to
the masses thank you ok I think I'll
start now I think I committed a very
serious crime by using PowerPoint
instead of using a mathematica notebook
but I was trying to copy a lot of images
it keeps crashing so I think I've excuse
ok so my topic is about how to deliver a
computation thinking to the masses when
I talk on mass is I mean as many people
as possible so starting from the I think
two years ago was the 70s el anniversary
of UNESCO and the chief secretary of
UNESCO actually announced that the edge
ecosyst education system in many
countries are not even relevant to
labour market opportunities at all
meaning that we are totally useless as a
professor okay and then this year i was
attending oecd in French they spell OCD
I didn't I didn't say wrong by any way
that the Minister of Education has
officially announced that our fish
intelligence and robots are changing
education needs but nobody is really
offering a comprehensive program from
the foundation so this is for the masses
in a sense that schools are changing so
the first thing that we know is they are
MOOCs they are so called school 42 is
totally a free program you don't even
pay for tuition you get to become a
programmer and supposedly that this is
going up in Paris and now in st. san
francisco and schools are trying to push
people out of out of their campuses
wanting them to become so-called
entrepreneurs and soco incubators are
becoming more like schools because
students are pushed out of those
campuses they don't have sufficient
skills and then they need actually there
is something so like Y Combinator is
very famous so-called incubator but they
are really kind of like a school so so
these things are really shifting the
paradigm the problem is that there are
no way
or at least not a very very rigorous way
of teaching people how to do
computational thinking until in 2006 a
Jeanette wing the computer science
department director of Carnegie Mellon
she wrote a paper on computational
thinking define what is and what is not
computational thinking and clearly
Stephen Wolfram has been talking about
competition thinking frequently and then
like two months ago he wrote this
article called how to teach computations
thinking and then soon send me a that's
last month actually um he he sent me an
e-mail say Ben you should be doing this
it just happens that I was actually
starting a brand new course called
companies computational thinking xinhua
so I said maybe I should talk about this
here at this conference so that's why
I'm here so so the things that these
people are not a masters both Stephen
Wolfram and Janelle wing are in the
masses they are the various normal
people they are the kind of people who
knows computations thinking but how can
we actually deliver the kind of ideas
they had Jeanette wing was very well
known for model checking I think very
few people in the masses actually know
what is model checking and steven is the
rate strange guy he's a super smart
person so they are the kind of thing
they talk about may or may not be
suitable for so called computational
thinking but there's one thing that's
important Stephens new book actually
talked about the key personalities in
computation thinking and it actually
connects many many dots that people like
myself can actually get into this so now
because the topic is about how to
deliver competition amasses so I knowing
p.m. in the United States I want to give
you some background information about my
context from the get-go the last two
years has been very transformative in
China primarily because we chat the
biggest like whatsapp application
started offering a peer-to-peer payment
so that profoundly changed the way
social dynamics works so I actually
completely stopped carrying cash and
complete stopped literally moving a
physical piece of money to any local
stores
on the streets and these kind of things
are again further fueled by the notion
of blockchain Bitcoin and then even as
you can see the central government's in
China are very much interested in notion
of using blocking technologies to
actually issue sovereignty money and
then people like the tablet build train
the person who designed the so-called is
etherium a smart contract they actually
bound itself it's a fiscal liability to
blocking or Bitcoin kind of currencies
he offers his own currency called his
theory and whatever coins or or money
and then these ideas either from the
top-down or bottom-up are changing the
way we think about what the future money
empower and also responsible eyes in the
problem is that very few people knows
how to really write smart contract very
few schools are teaching how to write
smart contract and and China knowing
this is the situations are trying to
push all schools to do make her
education get people to start doing 3d
printing if they were here learning
about Wolfram cloud they probably will
learn how to draw from cloud but
obviously Wolfram colors not very
popular in China at this moment I'm but
the notion of learning something about
parallel computation CUDA or GPU
programming is very popular in China but
still just knows how to write hardco
hardcore computer science code may or
not may not be computational thinking
for the masses let me explain why for
example um this is Larson Delmar a
chemistry professor in University of
California Davis about three years ago
he stopped asking the student to buy
textbook he makes his students to write
textbooks using wiki mediawiki in within
33 years he collected roughly about
20,000 pages worth of higher quality
text and then very quickly as you can
see from chemistry biology
geology so every single subject is now
accumulating many many texts at least 30
to 40 school sign up and about 7,000
students are writing textbooks for
themselves so when you start doing this
kind of work even though you are not
writing source code you are actually
using computational thinking because
your content is now being collected at a
massive level so so recently changed his
name called from UC Davis can be key to
liberty tax and you NSF found is very
very interesting so they've given quite
a bit of money and also science and
nature actually constantly asked him to
to write papers about how this will
revolutionize the way any other subject
matter is going to be chained by
network-based computational thought
processes so one of the founder of chem
week Iran Russa is coming to china next
week and that's why I'm leaving right
after this meeting immediately flying
back to John the pic pick him up but but
we are obviously also doing that with
him so all my courses right now are all
all the assignment all of the material
content is completely distributed using
wiki so we run our own local weekly
services in our department and I didn't
go to sleep last night because I was my
machine was hacked so I was you know
worried about this anyway so so
obviously just writing weekly alone is
not enough the National Open University
in China have more than like 10 million
people subscribe to their MOOC kind of
services but you can imagine the
tradition kind of MOOC service is
literally watching a video and probably
by email or by some kind of relatively
static content and send some homework
assignment back to the server so the
director of open university came to me
he asked Ben is there a way to actually
change this kind of paradigm can we
actually have better quality of delivery
and better quality of reception so we
are talking about tens of millions of
people then as a programmer in the past
I know there's a very simple saw
processes for all
programmers you need to first write test
which is called verification do the
right thing and then you need to somehow
test it in the real life environment
which is called validation the vm v the
two V's we're looking at here so
obviously if I just say V and V to the
director of these two big institution
they're just look at me what the hell
does that mean so so I have to try to
come down translating in three different
points the first thing is that in order
to get the message to understand what's
computation thinking we need to put them
back in the richer context secondly like
maybe people are not interested in
chemistry they may be not they are not
interesting Wolfram cloud but they may
be interesting in let's say fixing a car
or or running a above a cinnamon bun
shop right but can they actually
incorporate some kind of rigorous
thought processes some kind of
computational thinking processes the
second thing about getting people to do
things well and also being verified and
validated as a league a qualified
productive member of society then they
need to figure out how to write so call
contract with each other but it turns
out contracts are very logical items as
you know in the foundational company
computational science the notion of
contract design by contract is a very
very basic idea but obviously even some
programmers even myself when I was doing
this I was not really very formal
formally trained by this and the third
thing is when you have all these things
you need to somehow figure out a way to
constantly give feedback in the past
what special chinese students test is a
very powerful element but when you have
many many tests if they are repeated is
easily cheated therefore you need to
generate tests more importantly you want
to make chest useful and interactive so
that they actually learning things not
just at taking tests they are actually
doing productive work so to solve these
problems I came up with a generic
framework for teaching anybody
computational thinking
first front end it was the orientation
program and is based on the cognitive
foundation class but generally i
classify all my students into three
classes the egg B and C classes the a
classes people are so-called strategist
or business people or people who
believed strongly they will never learn
how to program but these people still
need to know what is computation
regardless the b-class people are people
who actually know computational techno
technical structure as well enough but
more importantly they need to actually
deliver the computational infrastructure
Tula masses through certain kind
architectural services like wolf and
cloud kind of thing and the third kind
of competition thing in people are
people in the trenches they may be
doctors they mean they may be
neurosurgeon they may be all kinds of
other very special specialized people or
a car mechanics but these courses also
as you can imagine the modern cars are
so smart it literally drives themselves
so these people as of now actually do
need to know a lot of a computational
thinking but the most important thing
about this ABC school is the notion of
recurse recursion meaning that all these
orientation programs are composed of
people from all three different classes
and then once they got into the
orientation program eventually as it
goes through the process they'll become
the designer of the program so refining
the entire curriculum by themselves so
this entire school is a learning machine
is a recursive production machine for
knowledge not just the notion of
teaching us particular subject matter
measuring the performance of individual
student we're talking about the entire
school as an organism and we want to
make this entire school as a device that
learn and it turns out there's another
program called brian robertson who wrote
this book about eight years ago called
whole accuracy how many people notice
about khalakka see heard of it no no one
okay so it's great so I was simply
sharing something new right so holacracy
was written by this programmer who
believe that in the modern ages in order
to have really flat and flexible
organization the best thing is that
everybody can figure out to become one
member in a circle and then basically by
defining their scope of management
everything is going to be managed just
by defining the membership defining the
rights and responsibilities for people
having certain membership and also the
official procedure to change the
responsibility and and rights of the
member so it turns out is a generic
abstract version of Constitution for any
organization and according to him there
are many many or organization that's
running very profitable operation
operations up to thousands of people
even sometimes the millions even many
hackerspaces around the world are using
electricity to run this so what I did is
the very first thing coming to my
classes is to either read it or actually
write it so just in August this coming
this past August I made this the
incoming student for my masters in
engineering students in the first four
days they were in my class they were
force them to actually completely
translate a 41-page of loan a
constitution into English form from
English to Chinese using wiki so they
are simultaneously learning how to use
wiki and editing a book and also come up
with nicer layout as well as a cover
design Oh in for 24 hours so literally
they are organizing them their own
resources using the principle accuracy
in running a autonomous in
self-organizing system and serving as
the operating system without necessarily
using computer other than using wiki so
on the other hand it turns out
computational thinking is not just about
writing code computation thinking is
about writing the controlling scripts
that control resources in general so to
make it very concrete about the notion
of masses that we know that the bitcoin
is a very big deal now in china so it
seventy percent of a bit coal mining
happens in China the transaction in
terms of actual American dollar
transaction volume also seventy percent
happens in China so he happens to be a
piece using our physics department he's
like 53 years old but he's still a very
very interesting a PhD student so so he
happens to know many many people in this
community so he organized this so-called
blockchain Association and got like 10
or 15 tops not all of them are in the
picture to become a instructor for my
ABC school so these people actually some
of them are the top programmer for
either ethereum or block chain they're
actually helping me design the APC
course in three different categories so
they are designing three layers of
course is teaching people how to
actually write a smart contract for for
investors for for for programmers and
for average people so obviously since we
are talking about how many computations
thinking we have to talk about what is
to be computed so the ABC course or any
courses I run because I force all my
students to use either get or use wiki
as the data capturing device so i can
very easily capture what they did this
is done in on 2014 in September the
incoming class so this is all the get
transaction so we can imagine all my
students even though they they are not
necessary programmers they have to learn
how to use kid right away and then then
I was able to capture very very precise
behavioral activity for these students
but obviously using get sometimes it's
difficult so that I started switching
over to using wiki this is a version
control for wiki and more specifically
this is one a wiki page my students
learned in my cognitive foundation class
so I knew this person must not have
copied this content directly from other
places just by reading the number of
changes and realizing the frequency of
changes is so high she must not have
been
copy the whole thing and because I try
it on the other nicer pages and I can
very quickly realize this completely
copy and how do I know again going back
to this process data so everything is
evidenced having a very precise evidence
so then you might wonder I have three
different kinds of classes what do I
teach in those classes so I have
shrieked in this case cocking foundation
system design in computational thinking
in industry frontier these are tailored
to three different groups of students so
instead of just thinking of individually
as people learning courses from me on
one particular subject matter I
intentionally make all three groups of
students synchronized and week-over-week
in trying to bring out similar topics
every week and make them right wiki
entries the kacatan foundation people
actually talk about metaphors because
metaphors is known by cognitive
scientists being the generic mechanism
for people to have any kind of
conscience or cognitive instrument and
then I actually make them to read and
write about category theory while I'm
getting students in the computation
thinking course to talk about different
kind of compiler design issues and then
the industry frontier people because
these people are focused on so-called
smart on transportations smart devices
and robotics so when they are talking
about writing smart contract I make them
make references to the other two kinds
of keywords so then the transaction on
specific stats for keyword naturally
shows up in a community about 100 people
so then over time oops it died I didn't
do anything oh okay microsoft also
crashed so it must be the images okay
let me try it again you know quit
Mathematica altogether I just proved to
you i also use Mathematica I'm not a
fake right
okay up again what said what'd you say
oh sorry yeah so okay so so this is one
of the animation that we actually wrote
this script using net logo and this some
of these are coming from the real data
from about four days of very intensive
scriptwriting wiki entry writing so we
can literally emulate a school about 100
people without them actually physically
showing up but obviously we were using
the actual data the reason I meant I
showed this to you is it turns out this
programming language called net logo
happens to have almost identical sets of
vocabulary because logo was from Lisp so
many of the terms was very much similar
to category theories notion of morphisms
arrows or functions and also object and
things of that sort obviously I'm not
going to talk about a category theory
here um but then there's another layer
of the important idea i think we
discovered this time that in the
beginning of this year that i discovered
this course called nantou tetris by an
omni song and the Shimon Shokan the tube
the two professors in Israel basically
spend about 15 years develop a course
they claim for people with zero
background you can build a computer from
transistor and using harder description
language finished in the first five
weeks a complete computer with cpu and
memory design and then the remaining
seven weeks you can actually do the
virtual machine compiler operating
system and write a simple a video game
like Tetris so I was a programmer I
never knew that I know even more than
two or three layers of least complex
complexity so I did the course myself
and it's been about five weeks according
to the website I only need to spend
about five hours per week to finish the
thing but probably because I'm getting
old I spend at least 15 hours per week
to get things done but after I got
things done I realized by knowing what
are the tricks using these sets of
automated tests I was able to compress
learning curve so much faster I was able
to get my son and my poor wife to
actually learn this by themselves in the
next three month so so so I haven't
finished I have to be honest I haven't
finished remaining six weeks I did
finish week six but the interesting part
of week six is that you have to write a
compiler or some kind translator
translating the 28,000 lines of assembly
language directly to machine language so
I have to again learn a programming
language to do the homework and then
knowing I'm coming here in this
conference so actually I did write the
entire compiler in Mathematica and it
was successful and it turns out to be a
very enjoyable experience but I should
probably spent about about 30 30 hours
for that but then the interesting part
of this is then I realized that you
should be very familiar with programming
before you start doing the remaining
part of courses anyway but I still tried
all these things on this is not my son
my son's friend so he came over and I
just want to show you very quickly of
the video and he was actually explaining
is I don't know what there is no sound
but uh that's fine just just imagine
he's he's speaking Chinese anyway you
wouldn't understand the word he said so
so but the point being that since we
started teaching this class here at
chinua right now we actually realized
the entire first five four weeks of
courses can be directly translating from
truth table using one functioning
boolean function automatically translate
into a boolean expression and we can
dump using Mathematica to solve the
problem completely obviously I didn't
show them to my students until this week
after they finish the homework
assignment
but more importantly the whole point is
that it turns out almost all kinds of
engineering tests regardless how complex
it is even if it is at least you know
seven layers of complexity almost every
layer can be translated back to some
kind of compiler implementation
assignment so then I realized that even
though I was doing my industrial
frontier course teaching people how to
write business strategy paper the whole
process is also a compilation and also
up digital publishing process so i
actually did write the home that the
homework and actually that wrote the
instruction for students to follow this
and and this is roughly the kind of
industry analysis but they were right so
it's very you know artistic and an
obvious a lot of labor involved in this
but it turns out by using a set of very
beautiful template anybody can do this
so so then I realize this recess of
course the ABC course can be actually
complimenting each other I know I only
have three minutes left so I want to
simply conclude the fact that regardless
of any kind of homework assignment they
are actually feeding each other on the
other hand computational thinking cannot
be taught as one course you need to
cover both the social societal part the
theoretical part the engineering part
and also more specifically the
organizational constitutional part so
that you can work with many other people
all together so one of the reasons I
have to come here to talk about this in
both from conferences that Wolfram
language is one of the pure or maybe the
pure is the functional language other
than a scale but in general functions
has many other aliases like arrow
amorphous and functor workflow processes
whatever they have but more importantly
all these ideas can be captured using
these type of concrete tools that we can
use everyday and it turns out regardless
what we call them everything has very
nice home in a digital space
so while I am I'm teaching my three
classes of students I realized that I
can i can use computational thinking
homework assignment to supplement the
information for my last technically
oriented students when they are writing
a business report in studying the
implication of blocking to the society
and what they while they are talking
about the big stories enticing people to
come these people can provide great
references to motivate people in cockney
foundation in other courses to know are
more technical details on the other hand
to deliver companies haitian thinking
that thinking must take place in richer
contacts if you know the right kind of
metaphor but when you are in a very rich
sets of contacts is very easy to get
lost therefore computational thinking
and specifically cognitive sciences
provides you three explicit simple types
of morphisms which are called
ontological metaphor spatial or
orientation metaphor in soco system
metaphor and it turns out there are
three fundamental types of functions in
general and then these kind of ideas can
be very useful in writing compilers and
then when you're writing compile you
have to have data to deal with either is
natural language text is hardware
description language is woven language
or any other languages everything must
be somehow become processable data then
these things becomes verifiable and
valuable and more importantly then
thinking can become computable if you
have data to deal with and then it turns
out whatever you are thinking unless you
write them down nobody knows what
happened therefore all computational
processes are just some kind of social
contracts will just keep refining them
only by having refinement as a process
we know we're thinking we think
therefore we are right but but more
importantly in order to know you are you
have to be social because you need to
have additional brains to bear
fire code is correct or not correct so
to conclude that we we just recently set
up a permanent research engineering
research institution with unesco etching
high university we are actually working
with many African countries and they
want to adopt this and we are working
with French the original school of
school 42 epi tech the largest computer
science school in in in France they are
providing as it was some of a technic
infrastructure to deliver computation
thinking to to French speaking people
and just last week I just received a
grant from British consul so I'm moving
chin huat student to Britt England and
England students who to chin Huat to
actually learn about this computation
thinking and extreme learning process
and to be specific that Oh a CD they
have this new kind of assessment for
creativity and critical thinking for all
citizens around the world but they are
not as of now adopting computational
thinking they thought design thinking
might be the solution but whatever the
solution is in order to make the masses
to receive proper education they need to
have better infrastructure they need to
have a rigorous framework so that's my
talk for today thank you
you